so it's great to be here at Simon's so I
want you to think about two-sided
matching markets we're matching
opportunities arrive overtime matching
is one to one and it is irreversible so
when I'm at a pair forms they will exit
the pool and these are features that are
shared by many markets that we care
about and by many models that we used to
think about this markets that we care
about so I'm thinking about child
adoption there location of public
housing the reassignment that occurs in
school choice has a consequence of
aftermarket and college admissions and
what I want to do is I'm going to
provide you with a theory of the set of
self-enforcing allocations in this
economics also known as stable matchings
now even though what I just described to
you is a simple extension to dynamic
environments of the Gale and Shapley
model it turns out that coming up with a
definition of stability for these
environments is not without difficulty
and there's something that probably you
guys already thought of which is all our
static stability notions are based on
the idea that all agents are present in
the economy to bargain effectively over
the outcomes but once we move into
dynamic environments it's not true that
all agents are there to match at the
same time and therefore to bargain over
the outcomes at the same time so what
we're defining what a blocking pair is
we will have to take into account this
restriction on the timing but more
importantly actually this will be
something easy to deal with more
importantly what will set outside a
dynamic matching market from its static
counterpart is the presence of an
externality in order to define given a
matching my payoff of waiting in the
market too much I will need to specify
everyone else's outcomes why because the
matching today by determining who
matches with whom today it determines
whether it's a set of unmatched agents
tomorrow together with the arrivals and
unless I know that set of agents I
cannot define what is the set of
feasible outcomes from tomorrow onwards
and clearly therefore I cannot define
one may pay office so that has to do
with how our definition of an accept
will have to be very careful with how we
define what an acceptable partner is so
what am I going to do I'm going to
provide you with a definition of
stability in dynamic matching markets at
very creativity I noted dynamic
stability I'm going to show you the
dynamically still matching success in
any finite horizon economy regardless of
how we the arrivals are distributed and
even though this definition is based on
an economy for in which are like I'm
thinking of a decentralized market when
you think about this definition I'm
going to show you two way to new
questions that we can start thinking
about design in this dynamic matching
markets that the just having the
definition makes it useful so before we
go into the analysis let me tell you at
least three reasons why I think this is
an important question
the first one is stability notions
usually give us a theory for the set of
self-enforcing allocations in an economy
that only depend on the payoff primitive
structure and this has been particularly
successful when people are doing
empirical analysis of this matching
markets because they don't need to think
a lot about what are the specific of the
game that the agents are playing in
order to be able to obtain preference
estimates that they can then use to
simulate other kinds of market designs
that they but now there's a whole host
of papers that are starting to study
empirically dynamic matching markets and
there's no such a tool that allows them
to do what we know how to excel the
second reason that we might care about
knowing how to define stability in the
dynamic economy is because there are
certain markets that we treat a static
that in fact they are not and one
example of this are the aftermarket
stereo currents called choice so most of
our school choice algorithms are
basically the other the public school
market is the only one that's there but
this actually coexist in a bigger market
where there's charter schools on private
schools and there's people coming out of
the district that the
for the school starts and this generates
that the school choice algorithms
actually have to run in in sequences so
the to accommodate these arrivals and
departures in as much as what the set as
the set of inasmuch that the set of
physics itself enforcing allocations in
the dynamic environment is different
from the set of self-enforcing
allocations in the static environment I
think that many people in the newsroom
that actually work on these problems
know that we're going to get into
trouble when we're looking at the
outcomes of these algorithms meant for
static matching markets and finally
there are already many markets that are
the central are the different versions
of this central si the centralized or
centralized markets that actually are
indeed like properly dynamic and
therefore as we use line stability as a
normative guide for they not studying
matching markets we could think of using
this dynamic notion of stability also as
a normative guide for this interaction
so people have seen any percent before
know that I'm a sucker for examples on
this presentation will not be any
exception so I'm going to spend quite a
bit of time going through ending a very
simple example and the idea is I want to
break down a notion of stability to two
things a definition of blocking pairs
and a definition of acceptable partners
and then I want to say that a matching
is stable if there's no blocking pairs
and there's no exception and there's no
and that's much to someone that is not
acceptable and the way that I'm going to
do it is I'm going to first show you
something very simple that we could have
done which is take the definition from
the static model and copy paste it into
the dynamic environment I'm going to
call that the core not because I don't
know that the current stability in
general they are not equal not just
because they want to have a different
word for the static notion than the one
news
that will give us one definition of the
set of a set of partners and blocking
pairs and then from that I'm going to
try to are you white maybe it's not the
best when were thinking about the
dynamic economy and I'm going to use
that to introduce the definition the one
thing that I don't want you to remember
from the example as being like a general
thing is that in the example the set of
dynamically still imagines will be as a
strict subset of the core this is in
general this is not a general result and
if you look at the paper there's
instances where the inclusion goes in
the opposite direction there's instances
in which they make non-overlapping
predictions after the example after the
example I think we can understand
basically so the example is going to be
very simple for presentational reasons
but basically there's going to be two
sides of the market agents on side they
are going to be [ __ ] and Gale sorry and
they're going to last for two periods
agents inside they are kunin Gale and
agents on site sorry I'm sorry who are I
appeared one and erazor arrives in
britain and agents inside we are sharply
who arrives in period one and Tucker and
Rani who are arriving period in a more
general model I will have a sequence of
sets a 1 a 2 a 3 18 and B 1 B and a
distribution over those sequences and
that will be the distribution which will
be commonly known will be a parameter of
the economy will be basically the
definition of the environment and the
sets determine basically the Preferences
the types of the agents and therefore
their preferences
now what we want to know here if we want
to find an assignment a matching that is
an assignment of agents on side a to
agents on side B that is self-enforcing
in the economy and one thing that we
might think of doing is say well look
actually you don't have a dynamic market
you have actually a two-sided static
matching market where you can hide in
agents preferences all the dynamics so
what do I mean by that well in this
static matching market you can see that
cone prefers to much with Tucker over
matching with Shapley whenever come
prefers to match with Tucker impure in
the second period over matching with
Shapley in the first period
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
lay out the Preferences for you of the
agents and then we will be able to
basically calculate the stable matchings
in this static matching market so I'm
going to assume that the agents are
discounted agility maximizers imagine
that pawn prefers to wait for Tucker
over matching e as they were running and
he prefers to much measly was running
over matching in me at Leawood sharply
but rain is not worth waiting for
so between matching would sharply today
and with rainy tomorrow rather match
with sharply today I'm going to denote
this in this way where the ones on the
zeros are basically the exponents in the
discount factor so this list gives me
the ranking of the discounted utilities
I can do the same thing for the rest of
the agents on site be on side a and for
the agents on side V I only need their
this their their utilities I'm not going
to put the ranking of the discontinuity
so now we have a static matching market
we have a way of calculating the set of
self-enforcing allocations and that is
the core so I'm matching is in the core
remember if there's no pair of agents
that refer too much together over
matching occurring too much the proposed
match and there's no one that would
rather remain single instead of matching
according to the proposed match
so in this example there are two matches
in the core one that comes from running
side be deferred acceptance and one that
comes from running side a deferred
acceptance and now you understand the
reason for the names so what I'm going
to show you next we are going to try to
get rid of that matching and only keep
them matching where the cores are
matched with each other so our goal in
the next couple of slides
it's just show that the matching from
side V deferred acceptance is not going
to be stable in the dynamic environment
but just to wrap up what we did we
basically applied one definition of what
is a set of blocking pairs and
acceptable partners in the dynamic
economy we said all agents are allowed
with a part of a blocking pair and an
agent is acceptable if he's better than
matching with myself now in the dynamic
economy one could argue that asking that
all pairs form a blocking pair is too
much because they're agents that we will
never meet and by allowing that everyone
from seblak impair the chorus allowing
agents that do not necessarily meet to
form this agreement to actually block a
matching outcome so what I'm going to
assume in the dynamic economy is that
only agents who are available to match
at the same time will form a blocking
pair and of course because these matches
were formed by assuming that no pair
forms of locking
of course they have no blocking pairs
when I reduce the subset oh but let me
illustrate what I mean by only agents
who are available to much of the same
time confirm a blocking pair so in
dynamic Stability kuhn and tucker would
not be able to form a blocking pair
because they don't according to this
matching they will never meet in the
economy but Galen Reni could form a
blocking pair because even though Gil
arrives in period one the matching says
that Gayle will meet Rennie and and
therefore I'm going to allow them to
form a blocking pair if they wanted to
as a consequence in the dynamic
environment the last period matching has
to be pairwise stable because otherwise
the agents admit them will object to it
by blocking so the question is now yes
so the thing is people that arrive in
the same period they always meet but
maybe I can block with someone in the
future because the matching will allow
me to be around when they arrive yes now
the question is how do we define what an
acceptable partner is and if this will
whether this is easy or not in this
example depends on which period the
agent arrives and then make simplify it
by looking at the matching that comes
through SIA be deferred
so the value of being single in this
economy really depends on the period
that I match what do I mean by this well
let's think of Gale he's supposed to
match in period two if he in period two
instead decides to remain single the
only thing the world ends so the only
thing that he can guarantee for himself
is the value of matching with himself so
that means that the period to match him
which we had already concluded has to be
Paraguay stable also has to be
individually rational in that people
have to get matched a matching partner
that they like at least as much as
matching with oneself but now let's
think of Cohn we supposed to match in
period one I'm going to calculate his
value of remaining single because that
will determine who is acceptable to him
or not but to calculate cons value of
remaining single in period in period one
we need to know what matching come
things will end soon
the moment he decides to wait to be
matched because without knowing what
match was some period - he cannot
calculate his plu of being matched but
notice that this is not only a
conjecture of what will happen in clear
tone to know what will happen in period
two he needs to know what will happen in
period one because the period one
matching will determine who remains
unmatched from period one and therefore
who the set of available agents to match
is Imperial tone and this is exactly the
same as what happens in the old papers
and newer ones on the non matching with
externalities were to be able to specify
someone's payoff I need to actually
specify everyone else's outcome so what
am I going to do let's start first by
ruling out what matchings own cannot
think are reasonable when he waits to be
matched so Kuhn under has understand
that in period two whoever is in the
economy when he waits
they will object to anything that is not
very stable
or individual irrational so any period
to matching that doesn't have those
characteristics the agents will bargain
it away so he shouldn't anticipate that
that's part of a continuation so
basically what he's saying is from
tomorrow onwards who are going to use
the same solution concept
how about period one well if Cohn
understands everyone's preferences
he shouldn't expect that agents that
match in period one are going to match
with someone that they don't like or
match in a way in which the dig in in a
way that they could have made an
improvement upon exiting by blocking
that outcome so I'm going he's going to
assume that amongst a set of agents that
leave the economy period one there was
no provides block and there was no one
that was matching in to someone that
they didn't like and basically what this
is saying is that Kuhn will not
anticipate that other agents will do
something quote unquote crease in period
one in order to prevent him from waiting
to be matched
now this potentially kills a lot of
matching SATCOM can conjecture but still
it's not enough to pin down Coons value
from Matt waiting to enlarge and
actually I can show you at least two
matches that are consistent with all
these conditions for Coons conjecture so
cool these are two magics that are that
satisfy this criterion so who matches in
period two because it is his prerogative
to wait to be matched and the period to
matching is stable and if someone is
matching because here I can only form
one matching period one it's not
matching its individual you Russian
so what am I going to learn I'm going to
say that when kun is thinking when when
kun is thinking about his value of
remaining unmatched he's going to act as
if his most pessimistic reasonable
conjecture will arise so he will rule
out all the matchings that I just told
him and then he will look from all those
matchings at the worst one and if that
matching is preferred to matching today
would sharply then he will decide to
remain unmatched and this is this is
something that's very common either in
the literature with externalities or the
literature that looks at Russia like
civility imagine and now indeed we have
been down conserve al you from waiting
too much you know that not that I know
because in the though so it it depends
the proof when the proof is constructive
and I use deferred acceptance in the
proof but you need to be able to
calculate agent payoffs from remaining
unmatched because that determines the
lists you put in different exceptions so
there's a there's first a calculation of
the continuation payoffs I will explain
that if I have time
mystic value is there a notion of
average or expected value in what sense
over arrivals and also the definitions
of the example in that sense is not very
good when they are looking when in the
case where arrivals are stochastic they
use the correct distribution over
arrivals the only the only thing that
they are doing is taking the mean over
the set of matching that they are
allowed to conjecture but the
distribution of arrivals is the correct
I know I did that Nikhil did I answer
your question thanks Ari ok ok
yes is the assumption that if deviance
Shapley will necessarily be unmatched no
no no no that's I will talk about that
at the end so now exactly so this is so
exactly this is one of the conjectures
that Kuhn is allowed to have that
sharply will say look you are leaving me
behind I'm going to go and find someone
else I'm going to take you and actually
the ability of doing this is very
important to guarantee existence and I'm
going to if I have time I will come back
to this at the end to compare exactly
the kinds of conjectures that you're
thinking of with respect to the set of
conjectures that I'm allowing for here
because in essence the that's a smaller
set of conjectures it imposes more
restrictions so and do you have any
generalizations of the notion of why
optimally
no there's no lattice structure here so
basically now so once so with this it
turns out that [ __ ] I'm not doing all
the possible matchings but [ __ ] can
actually guarantee that he will match
with Tucker in period 2 and therefore
that means that in the dynamic economy
Shapley is not acceptable to con and
therefore [ __ ] will block the matching
from the further acceptance on side B by
waiting so what the core is getting
wrong is at the core by defining that
Shapley's acceptable to con just because
sharply is better than single it's
ignoring cons continuation value in the
economy so basically what I'm going to
say is that I'm matching will be
dynamically stable if it is Paraguay
stable and that there's no pairs that
block amongst agents that are present at
the same time to match and no agent is
much to a partner that is worse than the
worst partner that he could obtain in a
matching that is dynamically stable in
the continuation and one way to think
about this most there's two ways to
think about this most pessimistic
conjecture one is imagine that it's you
doing do the analyst doing the exercise
and you're trying to think should come
weight or not in the economy if you know
that for any reasonable conjecture who
will do better than sharply then you
would be sure to say yes this outcome
come not occur but if there were some
conjectures for which cunning probes and
some for which his worse then you would
need to have a theory of how he forms
beliefs over there is noble matchings in
order to decide where it's good for him
to wait or not but also in more
complicated economies than the one that
I showed you here you can imagine that
through [ __ ] doing this calculation of
like what is everyone else going to do
what is going to happen tomorrow there's
a lot there is uncertainty in that so in
essence this is also me capturing the
complexity of the environment and I'm
saying corn will only wait if he's
certain that by waiting he makes an
improvement so what I'm going to do next
this is not going to make Vijay happy
but I'm going to show you a special case
of the model just because it will allow
me to put more formalism some pin-down
words into mathematical objects the
stochastic arrivals when I have the
slides at the end if you want to see
them but it requires more notation
because one has to keep track of the
realization of the arrivals now I want
the worst case no I want to do the worst
case you know I I don't do worst case
I'm going to informally introduce the
definition of stability and then I'm
going to show you how the existence
result works and then going to show you
that dynamic stability is a necessary
condition for agents to want to
participate in the market when they
arrive in that if the matching that I
put in the economy is not dynamically
stable then there will be an agent that
arrives in the economy and will benefit
from remaining outside and waiting a
little bit before they join and this
equals the result that we have for
studying markets that stability is a
necessary condition for agents to
participate in the economy and then so
that will be one way in which we can
think of designing dynamic matching
markets because we can think of another
way in which agents could try to
manipulate the matching which is very
hiding when they arrive in the economy
and then I'm going to talk about another
option for design which is why when do
we finalize matching and this will allow
me to talk about next point about what
happens for if I restrict the sort of
conjectures that the agents can help
if it's not stable and people would not
enter that the right time and weight is
does that lead to different applications
in the end or is it just a different way
of getting at the same you know why is
it beneficial for people to enter it
they're still not going to be matched
until the second well no so what
basically what the result will say is
that there will be someone that is
supposed that if they enter they would
be matched but because today but because
the matching is not dynamically stable
they will have and they will they will
benefit from from waiting outside one
period so I have a copy of this light oh
yes yes but no they're theirs so you
could say there is the follow you could
say there is a following relation which
is that both here and in the first
sighted cord the agents understand the
consequences of their decision to block
so they and here the there are
consequences that they anticipate the
dynamic that how the matching works but
contrary to farsighted stability here
someone blocks the world ends there's no
one anticipating any chain of like
further improvements or anything thank
you that's a nice analogy so the economy
is a finite horizon economy and you will
see if I get to show you a little bit of
how the proof works were the finite
horizon kicks in there's two sides a MMB
and they have the agents on both sides
draw characteristics from finite sets
calligraphic ARB this basically our
pinning down agents discount factors
under Bernoulli utilities for society
and the same foresight be think of the
payoff of matching with one soft equal
to zero I'm using this counting because
it's pretty standard but actually the
thing that matters is that preferences
are dynamically consistent so that if I
want to wait then I don't read
of course there's an uncertainty and
summarizations it might be bad but it's
not like I say I want to wait and then I
wait and then I say I want to take it
back so that's what really matters in
terms of the preferences for existence
an arrival on side a is our sequence of
sets a 1 through 8 a capital T I'm going
to assume that they are non-overlapping
but if you really like notation I have
it in the appendix of the paper how you
can have the notation for keeping track
of the agents and their types but this
makes the notation look very much not
like Gale and Shapley so I think this is
can you allow the perfect system
I want to sublet my house and I think I
have they want to sublet them at 14
I put wonderful things over the
fifteenth and I prefer the fourteenth of
the thirteen I can play my house a day
late over there you're needed but a
particular day if that leads to your
preferences over the dynamic allocations
to be dynamic consistency dynamically
consistent yes I cannot do that so
quickly in my head so I but what I need
is that your preference is over time
outcomes are dynamically consistent so
if you whatever is optimal for you today
then when you get tomorrow you want to
keep doing it I'm the same thing for a
site B arrival and I'm going to say that
the a with a bar T is basically everyone
that has arrived through period since a
day and the same for site B so an
economy is basically a sequence of
arrivals and if I had stochastic
arrivals it will be a distribution over
disguise it
so what is a matching impurity a
matching takes everyone else has arrived
through purity and gives them a matching
partner agents on site they have to
either match with themselves in which
case they remain single or to someone
else I'd be the same for agents inside
being what is a matching imagine will be
a sequence of period team matchings that
satisfy that whenever I match an agent
on side a from then on he keeps the same
matching partner because matching this
economy remember is irreversible now one
important piece of notation is that the
matching determines basically who is
available so much so if you give me a
matching through period t minus 1 the
set of people that I can match in period
t are the people that through period t
minus 1 are unmatched and the new
incoming arrivals that is my population
that's endogenous ly determined by the
matching elements and finally for
preferences if you give me an agent that
is unmatched at the beginning I can look
from the matching at the first day that
he will be matched and if he's never
match that's capital T and then I'm
going to look at the discounted utility
of matching with his terminal matching
partner because much is reversal
so I'm going to define dynamic stability
I want to do the same thing we did in
the example I'm going to define a set of
blocking pairs and then what it means
for someone to be able so imagine it's
pairwise stable if I cannot find a pair
a and B such that they're going to meet
in some period t minus 1 either
sorry in time period t either because
they are right before and they are still
unmatched or they arrived at different
periods and they happened to be
unmatched in this period
such that they prefer to match with each
other versus matching according to the
proposed outcome I'm calling this pair Y
stable because if there was one period
this is exactly the finish enough
provide stability so I have a new world
but the one thing that I need want to
emphasize is that a and B did not arrive
in the same period this is only thing is
that the matching allows them to meet
now this gives me a global sense of
provide stability I want something that
talks about they provide stability
within a period because I we said that
conjectures have to take into account
that people this period are not going to
do something crazy I'm going to say that
a period team match is stable amongst
those who match in period t if everyone
is matched in period t to someone that
is better than being single the matching
with oneself and the agents that match
an exit the economy in that period they
they didn't prefer to match with someone
that was
and also improve so contrary to the
other definition I'm only checking with
impurity but also country to the other
definition I'm asking for any real
rationality of the matching impurity the
other definition was only about blocking
pairs and our almost done so this is the
most difficult bit which is dynamic
stability is defined recursively so if I
want to define what some if something is
dynamically stable from - not from today
onwards I need to know what the set of
dynamically stable things from tomorrow
onwards are because that determines
agent configuration right so I'm going
to call the team okay oops I'm going to
call calligraphic DT the set of
dynamically still matchings for an
economy that lasts C periods so let's
fix a period t and imagine that you gave
me so I have if I if you give me period
t I have capital t minus T periods left
from tomorrow onwards and imagine that
you gave me these correspondences and
now let's take an agent that is
unmatched at the beginning of period t I
want to define what is the set of
matching he can conjecture I'm going to
say that agent K can conjecture
all matchings that satisfy the following
first through period t minus 1 the
matching has to coincide with what has
happened
so agent kick I'm not going and match
agency the path there is at first
restriction
the second is agent K has to be
unmatched in period t because it is his
prerogative to it the continuation
matching belongs in the set of
dynamically stable matchings from period
t plus 1 onwards so this is basically
the knot this is basically saying that
the matching that I'm conjecturing will
generate a continuation economy and I'm
going to draw the continuation matchings
from that continuation
economy and finally people in purity has
to have to match in a way that's stable
amongst the agents I feel I know because
it's yes so what is a dynamically stable
matching give me an economy of length
capital T and imagine that we already
defined what the set of dynamically
still outcomes is through period t minus
1 I'm going to ask that the matching is
Paraguay stable and that for every agent
inside a that is supposed to match in
period t there has to be some conjecture
that makes it so that he prefers to
match impurity over waiting to be
matched and the same for the agents on
side B and this basically defines the
set of matchings that are dynamically
stable for the economy of length capital
T so let me skip this the one thing I
want to point out before we go to the
results is the dynamically stable
matchings are individually rational so I
never asked in the definition of dynamic
stability that an agent is much to
someone that they prefer to remain in
single I think is that this arises and
this arises as a consequence of the
definition because it's a final period
no the no waiting means that I don't
want to be single I prefer the Matthew
to two remaining single but that means
that in period t minus 1 I know that by
waiting I get something at least as good
as being single and then this unravels
forward backwards which means that in
the dynamic economy the decision of
waiting to imagine is really replacing
the decision to remain single in the
static economy but now with the with the
added thing that now the continuation
value will be endogenous to the match in
a very poor because it's basically
example so differ yes if I decide to it
may not match in the first period but if
you did that much won't be stable right
if you get a higher value first like a I
didn't say I have not followed the
Phoenicians but like can make valuable
manning a match dependent when I decide
to exit and remain unmatched yes if it's
alright maybe I misunderstood by this
definition said you always have the
option to the where I may not match in
the last period because we're all dance
it's an example do I also have the
option is for you to just exited maximum
value you know if you're exit and remain
unmatched why would you exit if you're
never going to be hurt by staying in the
economy so people in this economy people
only exit when they are when they are
when they are matched but this is but
this is saying that when you're staying
you're getting something
can you say agents arrived today
if the arrivals are deterministic no if
the arrivals are stochastic yes because
if they are but it could be that we wait
because in some realizations for
instance you're going to get something
let's say it's yummy and you tell me
Laura look with some probability someone
way better comes and I'm going to leave
you alone and like back-up plan I will
be very happy
this is going on TV so I guess I have
five minutes six so let me skip the
proof of this because but but basically
the key is sorry the key idea in the
proof is that if I know agents
continuation values then I can for from
t plus 1 onwards I can truncate prefer
agents preferences in period t and run
da and then by doing this in the economy
moving from period one through period
thing I will be guaranteed of getting
something that is not blocked by anyone
waiting because I already incorporated
their continuation values and the crux
of the matter is just figuring out that
this matching in the end is forcible now
if someone in the audience remembers the
literature on the car with externalities
by imposing conjectures restrictions on
the conductors I didn't make my life
easier actually there are results that
say that if you don't allow for all
conjectures you might get non-existence
in a docile matching problem the reason
we will get existence is that these guys
are allowing for all kinds of perfect
salinities
arises in the dynamic column is a very
simple kind because I don't have it's
it's like a population externality not
survey effects or not so let me skip
this and Nick I want to get to your
question but I think this is sort of
interesting so let me there's this very
simple result which says the following
imagine that the economy lasts for two
periods and we do the further acceptance
like we did in the in the first example
we make the economy static and we just
run the first acceptance for side a it
turns out that no one on side a can
improve by waiting the outcome of the
different exceptions matching algorithm
and the result is I'm not saying it's
very surprising but what it's sort of
interesting is the proof because the
proof works by showing that if an agent
on say they only brought one side a
deferred acceptance algorithm by waiting
they could have submitted a line to the
deferred acceptance algorithm where they
submit their preferences as if they were
an agent that arrives in period two
and in a sense this opens up the
discussion that when we go into a
dynamic economy even if you new agents
preferences so when they see we've see
them you know that they want to go to
Harvard or actually they want to go to
Berkeley instead of going to Harvard
they they still can hide when they
arrive and actually we always have this
discussion of thickness versus thinness
in the timing of participation and
matching markets so there's two ways in
which they could actually manipulate
they could arrive in the economy and
just stay outside
I'm not join and this looks a little bit
like walking or they could enter the
economy hang around for a bit and right
before you're going to match exit and me
with expectation that they will rejoin
instant at some moment now dynamic
Stability already accounts a little bit
for the idea of no reneging because it
says at the moment that I'm going to
match it match you you have a reasonable
conjecture that you can not improve so
there's no incentive for me to renege at
that point on the economy it turns out
that dynamic stability also is a
necessary condition for no balking in
that if I set up a matching in the
economy that is not dynamically stable I
will be able to find an agent that would
when he supposed to enter the economy be
much he would prefer to stay outside and
join potentially the next period this is
just an echo in the dynamic environment
of the idea that stability is what
guarantees that agents want to join this
market and participate of the magic
I think that probably now my budget is
out two minutes so okay so let me talk
one second about the the thing that Nick
brought up so there's two ways in two
stories that we tell for stability in
the static market there's the story that
shows up in rows and Sotomayor but also
Norman which is the agents are unmatched
and there's this matchmaker that will
suggest a matching the agents can maybe
object to this matching maybe we specify
some reaction to what happens if someone
objects but if no one objects we're
going to match the agents the world ends
there's the other story for stability
which is the agents start from a
matching and now they start thinking am
i match to someone that I like can i
form a blocking pair and if someone's
thinking about this realizes that some
of the questions he has answered yes
then the matching is not stable when we
tell these two stories interchangeably
because this system is not important in
a matching where that static and has no
externalities I have two minutes over or
less but it will matter because the
dynamic matching market has an
externality for the definition that we
set up so Nick was asking me before
about what would happen if instead of
allowing people to match another way I
would keep everyone that is not me and
my matching partner matched to them
according to the matching that we were
looking at and you can think of this as
a passive conjecture so I'm going to
think that I'm the only smart person
that figured out that I have to wait so
much and everyone else stays put and
this is a very natural and this is
another natural definition but we know
this is a market with extra manatees you
put passive conjectures in a market with
externalities you're going to get
existence
now why does this matter and I will
finish with this because if we look at
some of the algorithms that people in
this room are looking even in school
choice the timing in school choice looks
a little bit like this I get my
assignment and before going to the next
round I have to think do I give my
assignment to the next period but I
cannot hope that when I decide to move
the plant the algorithm will go on and
match other agents to try to prevent me
from waiting so in as much as when we
change the timing at which matching and
blocking happens this changes the
predictions that we get from stability
we have to first be careful with what
happens with the algorithms that we run
and you know sometimes that school
choice algorithms can run very late into
the school year so even after private
schools have decided what they are going
to do this guy still running but just
because people but also we know that the
other definition doesn't have existence
issues so maybe it says that maybe we
have to start thinking very carefully
when we finalize matching our terms
because that's a policy variable that we
cover and potentially that might help us
to control
[Applause]
nice bro Ayano so so the thing is you
need to to calculate someone's
continuation values you need to be able
to necessarily sufficient
well I guess not because I could always
for me promise that you can show up
clearly if you're like I can't yeah for
Rene clearly not because you could say
from tomorrow onwards if you don't take
this I won't mention so yes this is my
ever sort of brushing so what I
shouldn't have said is this if it's
necessary enough it's necessary in a
salon ask you cannot you like if you can
if you can if you have to if you promise
nents of unfortunate locations yes but
if you have the power to tell agents
look if you don't take this this is all
you get then you can write an LP for
such that the corner points of these are
stable margins there is wondering can
you view this as essentially looking at
the dynamic program of which you say but
then this would naturally say that so I
each time I can either do a macho man
each person can be matched to the
continuously doing what we are computing
is there's a body function over all
possible targets
but I think so
I know I mean I by no means and I not
even that naive person in this thing's
like you know even worse than that but
because I was going to say an expert but
saying I'm not some expert yes like
that's also legit but I think that in
order for this to be efficient you will
need to be able to pick up of the
continuation values of each agent and I
don't think you can know you've got so
yeah so it would be a scotch or subject
yes so I don't know how the finding
continuation values you give a
definition for what the continuation
pool party should be yes very much
yes but no no what we're talking about
whether you can put it in a plate so
what I'm suggesting is that my variables
of my problem I think the problems are
about puts the complete watch know just
even for stable matching you can write a
larger thing then if the output is good
for the person who should be matched so
even though it that's a large but now
you can say that the last stage I could
complete this there's an extra thing
that you can create so this may not okay
I'm not sure if it works but that may be
one way to get around this problem so
the continuation values which will be
coupled because you're actually
outputting the entire not sure that's
true
so anything if you'd like to
it doesn't be great but a future
[Applause]
[Music]